why do you think your messaging got so
viral well this is the interesting thing
because
i didn't put a magic spell on the world
i'm not a magician you're right there's
obviously a market for what i say
every people talk about how i became the
most viral person on the planet i'll
argue the point not only do i become the
most viral person on the planet i did it
while being heavily shadow man
they've known about me for a while
they've been trying to shut me up for a
while i've been shadow banned forever so
i became the most viral person on the
planet with all the algorithms working
against me unlike people like logan who
have all the algorithms working for them
against me because i'm resonating with
people who are sitting there going
finally this makes sense to me this is
how i feel inside and this guy's finally
talking about it everything else i
consume is telling me to do things that
just don't resonate with my truth i'm
only saying things that people agree
with so to chop my head off and try and
delete me is astonishing in and of
itself because there are billions of
people out there millions of people out
there who feel the exact same way